here are 8 movies that improved my life and
maybe they'll improve yours too number one
catch me if you can catch me if you can as a
2002 film that is a true story obviously there
are probably some dramatic elements and it stars
Leo DiCaprio and Tom Hanks directed by Steven
Spielberg it's an absolute classic the film is
based on the life of Frank William abignale Jr
one of the most successful con men in American
history he effortlessly performed some of the
most depraved acts of deception by posing as a
Pan-American Airlines pilot a doctor in Georgia
and a prosecutor in Louisiana all before his 19th
birthday this guy was an absolute Prodigy while
I wouldn't recommend living your life like Frank
William I don't want you to con people more than
you already do but what this movie teaches
you is an invaluable lesson about how human
psychology works people know what you tell them
Carl Catch Me If You Can teaches you about the
power of presentation by the way you dress the
way you hold yourself you subconsciously signal
to people how they should treat you do you carry
yourself with dignity confidence Authority if not
what does that tell other people about how they
should treat you it makes you wonder how many
people that you look up to in life are actually
full of totally faking it they don't know anything
but they dress the part and have self-confidence
and on the flip side it makes you wonder how many
people genuinely know what they're talking about
have exceedingly valuable information but have no
presentation skills whatsoever so you perceive
whatever they're saying negatively presentation
is an amplifier it will amplify the good in you or
the bad in you and in this world tons of very bad
people have very high Charisma so if you perceive
yourself as a good person and you have strong
values I think it's a moral imperative to also
develop Charisma to present your self and your
information well to combat the evil charismatic
people in the world it's also just a fantastic
film it's so easy to watch so entertaining
and you will leave this film with some new
ideas I'm a celebrity Liberty in an emergency
can you catch me through on that line please
Groundhog Day Groundhog Day is a 1993 comedy
starring Bill Murray the story follows a
weatherman who finds himself reliving the same
day over and over and over again the thing I
love about Groundhog Day is that it's not only an
extremely easy film to watch it's also a profound
film about you and your own mental prison that
you can fall into if you're not careful Groundhog
Day is a metaphor for the prison of the self
Bill Murray's character was self-serving and he
robbed himself of Joy because of it every one
of his days felt agonizingly identical and he
wasn't able to escape it until he got outside
of himself because going outside of yourself
expands your world and adds meaning to your life
by watching Groundhog Day You Will Be Inspired to
do things you haven't done before to escape the
prison of your mind and stop being so selfish
so self-serving so inside it'll also inspire
you to detox your soul from irony poisoning
a thousand people freezing their butts off
waiting to worship a rat it'll help you identify
that skepticism sarcasm pessimism these things
will eat you alive okay campers rise and shine
I've been doing a little research on Aunt
Helen's tumor and it's totally clear that
anybody with familial abdominus palaposis should
be supplementing platinum-based doublet regiments
with icos and pentioic acid Limitless everybody
knows Limitless Limitless is a 2011 film starring
Bradley Cooper and Robert De Niro it's about a
struggling writer who gains access to a mysterious
drug that enhances his intellectual abilities
to superhuman levels but it also exposes him
to dangerous consequences I learned to play
the piano in three days Limitless is not art
I'll say it right now but its impact on me was
undeniable I watched Limitless on a plane when
I was 15 years old and it blew my mind it got me
thinking about the brain I have and how perhaps
I'm not using it to its full potential it
got me thinking that perhaps The Key to
Greatness is already within me everything that
I have ever learned is not forgotten but lying
dormant somewhere in my subconscious I I just
needed to find a way to access it my brain was
just pouring this stuff out everything I'd ever
read heard seen was now organized and available
here it is here you go this movie naturally
is everybody's gateway drug into biohacking
and nootropics if you don't know what nootropics
are they're brain enhancing supplements because
when you watch a movie about a guy who solves
all of his life problems by taking one mystery
pill gets you thinking about whether or not this
mystery pill exists in real life okay so what
do we have here some unknown untested possibly
Dangerous Drug scammed out of some unidentified
lab somewhere given to me by a highly unreliable
guy I hadn't seen in years so you want some more
yes definitely watching Limitless will inspire
you to use the brain you currently have to its
full potential it'll motivate you to think
about your problems differently and ask the
question if I were on nzt48 how would I solve this
problem if you haven't watched Limitless watch it
what I want you to hit me as hard as you can
let me tell you a little bit about Tyler Durden
there's not really much I can say about Fight
Club that hasn't been said in a billion he's
literally me montages or film analysis videos so
I'm gonna give you the overly simplistic take the
reason why you should watch it if you want to
improve your life is because of an energy Fight
Club represents an energy a simple thought that
of embracing chaos most of the time it's not the
actual external events that happen to you that
will ruin your life but it's your own fear of
bad things happening this constant rumination
that will rob you of Life your fear of death
will rob you of Life Fight Club will remind you
that the answer to your life's problems isn't
buying that new piece of Ikea furniture it's
not getting a matching cutlery set it's not
buying that beautiful sexy 2023 Toyota Tundra
because it won't make you happy it's all just
stupid because in a way these are all just ways
to avoid death they're all little consumeristic
traps that are basically a facade that Taps into
your instinct to self-preserve why do you need
a nice house why do you need a matching cutlery
set is that going to keep you from dying is that
going to keep the chaos at Bay in your life
by watching Fight Club you will become Bolder
more willing to take risk it'll really start to
get you thinking maybe discomfort not only isn't
really that bad but maybe it's exactly what I
need like a monkey ready to be shot into space
watching Fight Club will also permanently
imprint the character of Tyler Durden onto
your brain so when you're feeling a little
too comfortable you're afraid to ask a girl
out you're afraid to go for a run you can
ask yourself what would Tyler Durden do in
this situation once again not that Tyler Durden
is a shining example of how to live your life
but just like Frank William Abigail Jr movies
can have caricatures of the dramatic extreme
end of certain philosophies that you can
borrow when it's useful to you and then
discard when it's not tell you are by far the most
interesting single serving friend I've ever met
to have this thing everything on a plane is single
serving even though I get it it's very clever
how's that working out for you what being clever
anyways Watch Fight Club definitely awesome yeah I
mean if it's too much trouble you totally don't
have to but if you need someone I mean Duncan
yes there you go the way way back is an
underrated film not very many people have
heard of this it's a 2013 Coming of Age comedy
drama despite the fact that it's fairly unknown
it has some familiar faces in there we have Steve
Carell and Sam Rockwell most notably Steve Carell
in this movie is an absolute [__] he is not
even a little bit funny whereas Sam Rockwell
is very funny well actually Sam Rockwell is
always funny I'm gonna have to ask you to leave
what yeah you're gonna have to take off for
getting complaints you're having way too much
fun it's making everyone uncomfortable when you
watch The Way Way Back you just feel good and I
think the importance of that can't be understated
so much of what we soak in on social media wastes
your time and leaves you with absolutely nothing
but this film kind of brightens up your mood and
inspires you to be a good person it makes you
really look up to Sam Rockwell's character
because Sam Rockwell's character in the film
he doesn't really have it figured out he's a
smart ass a little bit of a deadbeat and probably
doesn't like himself very much but even though
he's going through a hard time he never lost his
Humanity he was able to identify that a young kid
looked up to him and with that knowledge he was
able to make a profound positive impact on him so
if you're going through a time in your life where
you feel like maybe you're not doing so well maybe
you're not qualified to help somebody out of a
bad situation I highly recommend watching the
way way back because it will remind you that
no matter where you are in life you have the
capacity for good that's why you can't buy
into that [__] you gotta go your own way
my friend you're going your own
way everything I have learned
I will teach you economics mathematics
philosophy science to read right
of course
when do we start The Count of Monte Cristo
this movie is so underrated The Count of
Monte Cristo is based on a novel by Alexandre
Dumas and it tells the story of Edmund Dantes
a man who is wrongfully imprisoned and then
seeks revenge against those who betrayed him
The Count of Monte Cristo is the perfect tale of
betrayal and Vengeance the main character Edmund
Dantes endures the worst torture imaginable and
then proceeds to have the biggest come up few
two things in life make me feel more vicariously
like a boss than seeing Edmund Dantes float down
on that balloon in his party it's like come at
me [__] I just arrived on a balloon this film
is highly inspiring it reminds you that in life
if you're stuck in the prison of Chateau deep if
you are currently in Your Darkest Timeline you
can keep your head down and make something out
of it so that when you're finally released from
the prison you're prepared you didn't use your
hardship as an excuse to waste away even though
you would have had every right to and nobody
would have blamed you isolation loneliness
captivity these things can all be leveraged
to your advantage there's an upside to almost
everything but you have to find it by watching
The Count of Monte Cristo you'll be inspired
to transform even the hardest times to your
advantage The Count of Monte Cristo will inspire
you to strike at the right moment and to have the
strength to take advantage of opportunity when
it presents itself because you've been training
you've been proactive it'll also inspire you to
go on an adventure to find lost treasure and have
the biggest come up of your life and overall just
be an absolute G life is a storm my young friend
you will bask in the sunlight one moment
be shattered on the Rocks the next
what makes you a man is what
you do when that storm comes
you must look into that storm and shout as you
didn't Rome do your worst for I will do mine
then the face will know you as we know
you as Albert mondago the man [Music]
what happened to your feet what do you mean these
are my 407s oh they're 407s can I see them yeah
yeah these offer a lot of
support right wow come on
what are you in a fraternity are you insane are
you in a fraternity you could have hit somebody
where was that that I'm asking a question you
have a fraternity no are you Steve Jobs what
okay crazy Stupid Love Crazy Stupid Love might
sound like a weird one on this list because it
kind of is but it's impact on me as a young
teen was undeniable Crazy Stupid Love is a
2011 romantic comedy starring Steve Carell once
again Ryan Gosling Julianne Moore and Emma Stone
and also Josh Groban he makes an appearance he's
got a banana it follows the story of a middle-aged
man who after his wife asks for a divorce seeks
help from a young Bachelor to navigate the dating
scene basically the utility of Crazy Stupid Love
You know you'll probably have your own takeaways
from it but my own takeaway when I watched it for
the first time is that Ryan Gosling is a cool guy
Ryan Gosling's character in Crazy Stupid Love
was kind of my fashion and Charisma icon as a
teenager this film taught me to be better
than the Gap and to ditch my velcro wallet
what are your wallet it also inspired me to not be
a bumbling doofus I'm a cuckold to put more effort
into you know the way I dress the way I present
myself and just be a cooler guy in general but
the thing about Crazy Stupid Love Is that Ryan
Gosling's character isn't without his flaws he's
kind of a slimy womanizer who has no soul which
is the nice thing about Crazy Stupid Love it's a
very human film I like the message in this movie
it'll get you thinking like yeah you know what
I should dress better I should have some ribs I
should I should take care of myself but happiness
isn't found in buying things or using people
but rather in giving and in sharing life with
the people that you love so absolutely take care
of your appearance because you're dignified so
you should reflect that dignity by the way that
you dress but to weaponize aesthetic virtue to
absorb pleasure from others it's a vacuous
behavior that will leave you Hollow in the
long run this is what happened to Ryan Gosling's
character he used his Ryan Gosling looks and style
to take advantage of people for his own pleasure
and it left him Hollow and profoundly lonely in
the long run whereas Steve Carell's character was
sort of on the opposite side of the spectrum he
loved and cared for his kids but he sort of lost
respect for himself stopped taking care of himself
the balance is somewhere right in the middle where
you're not so self-absorbed but you take care of
yourself so that you can increase your capacity to
take care of others because ultimately that's what
helps give life meaning take care elf okay guys
hear me out elf is a 2003 Christmas comedy film
directed by John Favreau starring Will Ferrell
it tells the story of a human who was raised by
elves at the North Pole and travels to New York
City in search of his true identity see okay
elf it's not a great movie I you know as a movie
you know I don't know guys he's an angry elf but
I'd be lying if I said this movie didn't stick
with me and that's because of the Father Figure
the father figure of elf is the emotional heart
of the movie he sort of plays the straight man
character everybody can identify with the father
figure it makes you wonder what would you do in
this situation if this absolute freak mentally
unstable man-child entered your life how would
you deal with it what if he was your son like you
don't have to watch this movie it's not very good
okay guys I actually have like eight more movies
in front of me but I'm just running out of time to
talk about them so if you want me to continue this
series let me know in the comments section below
thank you for watching this video is sponsored by
athletic greens ag-1 makes it insanely easy for me
to make sure that I'm hitting my nutritional goals
out of all of the multivitamins or supplements
that I've ever taken athletic greens has by far
the most complex nutritional profile packed with
over 75 vitamins minerals Whole Foods or
superfoods and adaptogens in every single
scoop ag1 makes sure that you're giving your body
everything it needs to feel energized and focused
throughout the day my favorite thing about ag-1 is
that it's made from Whole Foods so it ensures that
it's extremely bioavailable which means that your
body absorbs it very easily and you don't just
urinate it out like so many cheaper multivitamins
so if you're interested in joining Me In by far
the simplest way to meet your nutritional needs
then if you use my link in the description below
you'll also get a year's supply of their vitamin
D3 and K2 complex which I also have every single
morning as well as five ag1 travel tax with
your first purchase so once again make sure
to take advantage of that link below and thank you
again to athletic greens for sponsoring this video